joining us now with reaction is Megan
McCaleb she's one of 65 women who knew
Kavanagh in high school who wrote a
letter supporting him Helga Walker
worked with Brett Kavanaugh in the White
House counsel's office and Porter
Wilkinson is a former clerk for judge
Kavanagh helgi let's start with you of
the entire panel probably you've known
Brett Kavanaugh the longest and I am
livid about what they're doing to him I
can imagine you are as well your
reaction Laura you and I have been
friends with judge Kavanaugh we used to
call him Brett for 25 years I've also
worked with him in the White House
counsel's office side-by-side every day
he treated me like a serious lawyer like
his equal like his teammate in every
fashion he took me seriously he debated
issues with me this is a man who treats
women with the utmost respect courtesy
he's a complete gentleman
he's a kind and a gentle and a decent
person and it makes me upset to Laura
that somebody who is willing to be on
the Supreme Court who we are fortunate
to have a person of those qualifications
be willing to serve to be smeared like
this at the very last minute was such an
obvious attempt to try to stop him or at
least tarnish him in some way because
some people just can't accept the fact
that he is so well-qualified I'm gonna
get command that he is gonna be on the
Supreme Court Megan I want to go to you
because there has been some whispering
around Washington about this letter the
65 classmates who signed this letter in
support of judge Kavanagh and it was
said that this letter had been written
long ago is that is that the case
because I know you signed it I just want
to clear that up once and for all no it
is that is absolutely not the case we
got wind of this yesterday from my
husband received a call from a reporter
with those those allegations and we we
couldn't believe it absolutely couldn't
believe it I've known Bret since I was a
freshman in high school and we knew we
had to rally around him
I mean you've known him since high
school you have none of
longer than even we have and it's
anything in his character indicate
behavior such as that is alleged today
again by an anonymous person and a
letter that that Feinstein sat on since
July anything in his background her
character absolutely nothing he always
treated us with girl girls with respect
always and it was simple to find 65
women to sign that letter from five
different high schools everybody jumped
on board and was happy to sign it on his
behalf and they all saw it and agreed
with it I have to say I think this is a
big embarrassment for the me2 movement
there are legitimate claims that have
been raised and voiced and people put
their names behind those claims and
accusations even if they're long ago
this is someone who refuses to give her
name for whatever reason and it ends up
in the hands of Dianne Feinstein had
never released Porter I have to ask you
about this what about those
circumstances Dianne Feinstein doing
this in this way well I'm not a
political commentator and so I don't
have a lot to say about shops
Dianne Feinstein has handled this
besides for the fact that I believe that
she takes the concerns of women
seriously and if she thought that there
was a serious credible allegation here
that she would have come forth sooner
and said something and during the FBI
background check or the hearing tell us
about Judge Cavanaugh the boss it was a
law clerk to judge Cavanaugh in 2007 and
2008 and I worked closely with him day
in and day out helping him prepare for
cases and decide cases and he is
unfailingly kind and respectful and a
man of the highest character
unassailable integrity and these
allegations are flatly inconsistent with
the man that I've known well for over a
decade you know it's amazing ladies is
that there was a tweet from Obama's top
guy Brian Fallon the campaign was a
Hillary Hillary's campaign excuse me and
he tweeted this out today in response to
this Emily singer tweet
Emily singer tweeted makes the whole
bring in the daughter's basketball team
and talk about how great a coach he was
look even more transparent and then
Fallon's tweets back and his
phasis on hiring women clerks I'd like
you to respond to that so in other words
he hired female clerks for 12 years in
anticipation of being nominated to the
Supreme Court Porter Laura I'm not alone
in my assessment of judge Kavanagh I
think you know that women from every
phase of his life have written letters
to the Senate Judiciary Committee
supporting his nomination every single
one of his female clerks who wasn't
prohibited from signing a letter based
on their current employment vouch for
his character his integrity the fact
that it is because of him that they are
succeeding in their careers there's a
moment in an interview I did with
Justice Thomas last november's when we
just started the Ingraham angle about
whether this whole process and what he
went through again an eleventh-hour hit
leaked FBI memo that was already
investigated by the FBI and and
dismissed accusations by Anita Hill and
this is what he said let's watch 28
years ago you went through the worst
confirmation spectacle in history was it
worth it I think we are called to do
certain things I don't thinks anyone
would choose to go through
unpleasantness but if it has to be that
to do what is right and so be it okay
well I clerk for Justice Thomas like you
did Laura were part of that special
family and it's just so disappointing
that the confirmation process and the
Senate Judiciary Committee has sunk so
low we could be having a conversation
about the Constitution we could be
having a conversation about the 300
opinions that Judge Cavanaugh has
written we could be talking about the
future of our country instead we're
talking about trash smut anonymous
allegations and even justice Ginsberg
yesterday a liberal icon a fighter for
women's rights respected by so many
people across the aisle said the
confirmation process the way it is now
is wrong so if liberals don't believe
Justice Ginsburg then I don't know who
they'll listen to Megan have you been in
touch with judge Kavanagh how is he
doing how is his family doing throughout
this process it certainly was
and that confirmation hearing especially
when they had the planned protests and
you had you know all the usual suspects
disrupting the proceedings for so long
you know I saw them at the hearings and
they're doing as well as to be expected
no well there was one moment there was
one moment last night and I want you
guys to respond maybe Hellgate this is
lawrence O'Donnell raising this issue of
this allegation let's watch the fact
that the senator and congresswoman su
issued statements about it today and
took this step senator Feinstein took
the step to the FBI was what is where we
are now and we do not know where we're
going to be tomorrow no this is I mean
we we overuse the word unprecedented but
for Supreme Court nominations even with
the Clarence Thomas background
this is absolutely unprecedented
even at morning Joe this morning had to
say this is kind of a they were they
can't stand Trump at Morning Joe even
they were saying come on guys this is no
this is this is you've made a mockery of
the Senate confirmation process for the
Supreme Court we have all these
incredibly impressive women Porter is
not a political person decided to come
on and put her name out there tonight
obviously Megan you did the same thing
Halligan you have better things to do
but you're out here just to stand
against unfairness and I would like
American women to know that all of the
women on this set today are accomplished
impressive women excluding myself who
have things to say and we all think he's
great and would you take the word of
people who have known him for 25 years
or would you listen to this ridiculous
last-minute character it says all of you
thank you so much for joining us tonight